hey everyone what's happening it's my
you go today I'm going to be going over
some of my tips and tricks for how to
study for the technical interview which
is a typical part of the software
engineering interview process whether
you're interviewing for an internship or
a full-time job I hope these tips will
help you ace your next technical
interview so when interviewing for a
software engineering job there's usually
three stages the phone screen the
technical phone interview and the
on-site today we're going to be focusing
on the technical interview which is a
core part of the technical phone
interview and the on-site I might make
another video for the other parts but my
advice here actually applies pretty
generally to all of the stages so
hopefully they help alright ready here
we go my first tip is to study and this
might sound weird or dumber cliche but
really study for your interview
companies used a technical interview as
a part of the standard interview process
in order to assess your technical
ability ideally the problems that you
encounter in the central interview are
the types of problems that you would
encounter IRL at this job because that
gives a true measure on how you would do
should you work there and for companies
that don't do this I'm looking at you
what are you really gonna learn from
asking someone how many ping-pong balls
fit into an airplane now all of that
aside and sometimes those are the types
of questions you might get what you're
called brain teaser questions the
technical interview is there to assess
how you solve problems anyways here are
my favorite resources for studying for
technical interviews the first is
cracking the coding interview now I know
y'all have heard me talk about this
before but cracking the coding interview
is basically like the Holy Bible of
studying for technical interviews I have
my copy right here which is the fifth
edition and I wanna say yeah it's the
fifth edition and it's it's got all my
highlights and stuff in there but this
is so useful when it comes to setting
for a technical interview it includes
refreshers for computer science concepts
and a bunch of practice problems with
answers in the back this book is written
based on the technical interviews from
big companies like Google Apple Amazon
and Microsoft Anu did
is released every year so that it's
always kept up to date that said if you
don't get the latest edition inside such
a big deal but it is cool to see like
the latest editions of stuff because
they're going to reflect what the
interview process is like at those
companies currently I'll leave a link to
buy the book down in the description box
below the second tool I use is called
Lee code it has thousands of crowdsource
interview questions that you can work on
in an online editor so it'll give here a
problem and then you can code out your
solution and then what it does is it
runs it against a bunch of tests so you
can see whether your solution works or
not the problems variant difficulty and
you can use what programming language
that you're most comfortable with
I use this hand-in-hand with cracking
the coding interview the fact that it's
an online editor really mimics a
technical phone screen and it gets me
into the right mindset so my next tip is
to study for the specific technology now
I'm leaving this at like a 1.5 because
this may not apply to everyone if you're
interviewing for a role specializing in
a specific technology or a stack and
you'll notice by looking at the job
description then you're definitely going
to want to study the concepts associated
to that technology or stack for instance
I'm an iOS engineer and so when I'm
studying for interviews I'm brushing up
on core iOS concepts and frameworks like
UI kit for example my friend and web
engineer friends will brush up on things
like JavaScript and react instead using
this knowledge as part of your technical
interview will exemplify your level of
mastery with this technology will give
companies a better sense of where you
stand in terms of your experience okay
so my next tip is to study with a buddy
okay this is probably actually the most
important piece of advice that I have
for you in studying for a technical
interview we mentioned a little bit
about this in my Q&A with Jarvis video
but when companies are giving you a
technical interview they're actually not
as interested in you arriving at the
right answer as they are seeing what
your thought process is like but may you
didn't you just say you needed to brush
up on core technical concepts in order
to do well in your technical interview
well yeah but the way that I think about
it is that you're better equipped to
solve these problems if you have the
right tools in hand
those tools in this case are being able
to recall computer science concepts and
frameworks in order for you to solve
your problem well imagine if someone
told you to build a table without any
tools you're much better off
successfully figuring out how to build
the table if you have those tools right
so once you have your technical chops
back up to snuff from studying then find
a buddy to do a mock interview with you
they can pretend to be the interviewer
and give you the interview problem you
can practice thinking out loud as you
would in a real technical interview and
the act of doing this will just get you
so much more comfortable with
articulating your thought process now
not articulating your thought process in
a technical interview is actually where
most interviews go awry if you're not
explaining what you're thinking then
your interviewer has no chance to
course-correct you towards the right
direction and they actually don't get
very much information or insight into
how you solve problems which is exactly
what they want to find out in this
interview so to try this out with a
buddy and at the end of your mock
interview ask your feedback on what you
did well and what you didn't do well you
can take this feedback as ways to
improve your next mock interview or for
your actual technical interview my last
piece of feedback is to relax and you're
gonna be just fine
I know that interviews are scary and
talking to an interviewer to prove your
worth is downright terrifying but know
that you are going to own this if you
want study and to practice with a buddy
to know that you can walk in there with
confidence because you've prepared for
your technical interview do whatever it
is that you need to do in order to get
yourself amped and ready for this
interview I personally like power posing
for two minutes right before my
interview
also remember that everything is a
process and so there might be some
rockiness along the way interviews can
be really competitive they could only be
one spot but a thousand applicants but
know that preparing and going in there
and giving it your all is so much better
than not trying at all do or do not
there is no try with all things in life
remember that each bump in the road is a
new lesson that can be learned that you
can take with you next time so
regardless of the result I highly
recommend you follow up with your
interviewer if you can to ask for
feedback on what you can improve on be
usually more than willing to help on
this and you can take these lessons with
you for your next interview just
remember to take a deep breath and stay
positive during your interview be polite
inquisitive and thoughtful and you're
going to do great I know that you can do
this all right so these are my tips for
how to study for a technical interview
remember to study and sometimes for
specific technologies practice with the
buddy and remember that you're going to
do great leave a comment down below for
your favorite interview tips and tricks
I'd love to hear them
also if you know of someone who's
interviewing for a job right now then
please share this video with them and
don't forget to give this video a thumbs
up if you liked it and subscribe to my
channel for more videos good luck on
your interview and I'll see you next
time bye
[Music]